hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu christmas kraft
folgen um eur 9
ich halte jetzt einfach meiner dazu
nehme ich dann hat er es behindert wir
haben wir letztes mal diesem tollen
schneemann da den ihr da seht da seht
ihr sein gesicht neben meinem tollen
prachtvollen adonis gesicht was ihnen
wie immer näher
und jetzt bin ich in mir drin das
komisch na gut ich habe ja letztes mal
in der folge gesagt dass ich heute einen
weihnachtsmarkt bauen wäre das werte ich
allerdings auf 3
pabst verschieben das heißt die schwert
in diesem park anfangen mit der mit der
mit der materie mit dem weihnachtsmarkt
er sieht übrigens kommentare oben links
eingeblendet und anfang mit dem us markt
beziehungsweise erstmal eine
schlittschuhbahn machen dann in dem
zweiten dritten partner in die
weihnachtsmann macht weihnachts mit den
weihnachtsmarkt machen mein gott und
zwar weiß ich glaub ich mach das einfach
hier überall zwischendurch ein paar
häuschen nur erstmal die shootings also
übrigens die idee mit dem
weihnachtsmarkt kampf von warte ich habe
gelesen gelesen die jungs irgendwas und
das thema ist hier mit dem vorschlag
also wie findest du es wenn du am 24 12
2012 geburtstag hätte ist lg helios also
helios lp danke für das thema ist ein
interessantes thema mit so einem thema
hätte ich ehrlich gesagt rein gar nicht
gerechnet wisst ihr was wo könig in die
linke machen die schlittschuhe dings ich
mache eine kleine ich mache hier unten
hin
das ist ein thema das ist ein recht
absurdes damit also einem thema mit dem
ich echt nicht gerechnet und mein gott
das sind relativ durchaus mit dem
komischen
klares ja
als
der wassersport darunter allerdings
sport und allerdings
allerdings darunter schnee sonst der
origami schön aus mein gott vor allem an
die sie gar nicht sehen das ist ja auch
komisch
also ich habe eigentlich gar nicht zu
doch nachgedacht was werden so wenig
wenn ich dein geburtstag hätte was
werden das den unterschied so genannter
sitzt wahrscheinlich so nach dem motto
am 24 kompanie geschenkt bekommt zu
ballern doppelt geschenkt oder hin so
was kann eine person ihren fünfzigsten
geburtstag das ist auf jeden fall sehr
hoch weil eigentlich jetzt dass der mann
hat im februar geburtstag am 21 februar
kalender eintragen gratulieren und zogen
manchmal will ich gar nicht dass die mir
alle gratuliert sonst kann man sitzt
emilian leute vom militär zu 60.000
lebensfern bisschen beängstigend
naja jedenfalls zum thema zurückzukommen
mein gott hat mich dann auch links zu
setzen
zum thema zurückzukommen was soll ich
sagen
achso und zweirad diese person mein
kumpel hat am 25 geburtstag bei dem es
ist so dass er damit ich weniger
geschenke bekommt weil ganz einfach weil
am 24
menge bekommt von fünf sitzen und das
ist eigentlich ganz los eigentlich hat
man ja irgendwie sollen mitte des jahres
geburtstag hauptsächlich meistern
wirklich so im sommer geburtstag und
zwar sagen wir mal die ab dem juni
geburtstag damit kommt im juni geschenke
und an weihnachten ist er wieder sechs
monate später also dann bekommt ihr halt
wieder hätten die menge geschenke wenn
euer geburtstag und euer und weihnachten
sage ich weil es so nah aneinander liegt
dass ihr das 24 stunden zwischen sind
beziehungsweise das direkt auf einem
taxi natürlich klar dass ihr nicht
doppelt weh geschenke bekommt statt nur
genau dann geburtstag von jesus christus
geburtstag ab und könnte der winter
jesus christus an eine so dass die
eisbahn man sieht zwar jetzt nicht so
heftig dass herr unterwegs ist ja ist es
schnee
vor allem jetzt nicht wenn ich noch was
turm gebaut hat und dass der weg gemacht
hat was auch noch im dorf als die plätze
am rand durchschimmert aber trotzdem
erkennt man das irgendwie nicht so ein
bisschen schnee darüber blabla natürlich
verbaut so das ist ein geschenk die
eisbahn können jetzt noch mehr an den
rand hier warte ich zeigen was ich
machen könnte
dann habe ich dann wo ich dann kann ich
sein tag da das habe ich doch herrlich
da ist sich könnten rand halten womit
der tier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
dollar 345 6 723 sorgen machen wir hier
nicht einfach hin nicht längst sondern
einfach immer so an die enden so lampe 1
52 eine schlittschuhbahn ein bisschen
beleuchtet ist eher was ich denke ich
grenzt dieser ein bisschen ein mit
seiner koppel stores die kommission
hatte ich schon ganz kurz fasste der
unterschied ich denke ich mach's mit der
die sieht irgendwie klima aus damit
können wir das ganze jeder noch ein
bisschen eingrenzen sage ich mal
das ist falsch investiert was ich glaube
ich bau dir auch noch diesen komischen
steine damit dass ein passender war
gerade die jetzt sagen das wird das
alles miteinander verbunden ist
das weiß auf welchem platz des werd ich
mein respekt weil das einfach eine wilde
szene die mir grad einfach so
eingefallen ist vor gott sage ich dass
wir schon zu wasser nur weil jetzt
lampis erwartet
nein denn das wasser wird können wir
einfach auf wasser drauf füllen
ja okay das altwasser watte packen
einfach in seinem jüngsten platte dies
ein bisschen ice halt ich gehalten kann
man ja auch irgendwie so ausschöpfen
wenn man will kann man gar nicht gut
aber kann sich auf jeden fall hin setzen
das ist dann die eisbahn
ich kenne mal ganz kurz gucken sich das
ja eigentlich alles bei nacht aus
solchen nur mal gucken wollen die
beleuchtung beim bauern auf jeden fall
beleuchtung adventskranz und da werde
ich also ich denke wenn ihr dann
allerdings kommt der komplette markt
wenn wir das ganze noch ein bisschen
cooler gut dann will ich sagen was mit
folge 9
wir haben ja heute wenn ihr diese folge
wtf den heute sonntag
naja okay stimmt sogar wären heute
sonntag dass ich war total verwirrt weil
hält sonntag das haben heute sonntag das
heißt morgen ist das erste was heißt
heute die letzte chance und nochmal
kommentare zu schreiben mit witzigen
geschichten um morgen 1 von drei spielen
zu gewinnen
bisher sei einer von drei glücklichen
gewinnern zu sein selbst trinke ich noch
mal an ich hab noch keine sachen
rausgesucht das heißt jeder die gleiche
chance schreibt mir ganz ganz viele
sachen die kommentare und auch noch bei
vorträgen und themenvorschläge um
eventuell im nächsten video dann erwähnt
zu werden
schaffen wir eventuell für diese tolle
kleine stefan hier 555 daumen hoch das
fast 550 waren es
obwohl es ist wieder soweit 50